all right as you can see it is December
now so I'm wearing my rainbow cardigan
which I wear with no shame and I've got
the fireplace goal the fireplace isn't
really going but it's there so I've got
the whole Christmas vibe the Advent vibe
I should say I'm going to get myself
into trouble by giving a horribly
offensive opinion today inappropriate
frankly just terrible opinion about
something
Kareem hunt is it was the star running
back of the Kansas City Chiefs the
Kansas City Chiefs who by the way are
playing my Baltimore Ravens this coming
Sunday which is really not relevant to
the point at all but I just thought I'd
mention it
hunt was cut from his team and suspended
by the league after video surfaced
security camera footage came out of hunt
allegedly brutalizing a woman at a at a
hotel in Cleveland several months ago
now I use the word brutalize and there
are quotes around it because that's the
word that the media has used and that's
the word that TMZ which obtained the
video and put it out originally there
though that's that's the one that they
use to describe the videos it's hunt
brutalizing a woman now if you um if you
watch the video that's not exactly what
you see I don't know if I would use the
word brutalize I mean brutalize is when
you hear oh there's video of an NFL
player brutalizing a woman it puts a
certain image in your mind right away
right and then well that's not exactly
what you see what you see if you watch
the video footage and it's just there's
no audio it's just the visual you see
hunt along with some other guys in the
hallway of a hotel you see you could
tell just from even without any words or
anything you could tell that they all
occur to be drunk you see the guys you
see a group of women as well you see
that the women and the men are shouting
at each other one of the guys hunt is
really upset about something is getting
very angry and he's yelling at
particular at another woman who's who's
yelling at him and they're shouting at
each other at one point he shoves her to
get her out of his face but she comes
back and then smacks him in the face
and then she keeps coming at this point
his friends are holding him back and she
keeps coming back to him now this guy is
obviously furious he's just been smacked
to the face she keeps coming back to him
at one point she she she gets knocked
over when when a guy is knocked over and
then falls into her accidentally she
falls on the ground then a couple of
minutes later as hunt is walking by the
woman while she's kind of crouched on
the ground he kicks her in apparently
looks like maybe in the thigh or the leg
or something like that and that's the
end of the video now this has gotten a
lot of attention people are outraged at
hunt everybody is outraged as I said he
lost his job it's you know he's
suspended by the league there are some
people think he'll never play again and
I think he probably will play again in
the league but you know everyone's very
upset and it's he deserved people people
should be upset at him he does it he
behaves terribly in the video he could
have just walked away but he didn't and
the kick at the end was clearly
egregious but let's just imagine
something for a moment okay
imagine the exact same situation
everything is exactly the same except
the woman is a man okay so imagine that
everything's exactly the same but the
woman is a man and let's just say that
the man is the the man is the exact same
you know the same height weight
everything as the woman so let's say
it's a it's a scrawny little white guy
and he's getting into a shouting match
with this NFL player he gets shot he
comes back smacks the NFL player in the
face keeps coming back at him eventually
he's knocked over and hunt kicks him
okay imagine that now do you think
there'd be anywhere near the same level
of outrage do you think that hunt would
potentially lose his whole career ever
do you think he even would have lost his
job do you think they would have even
gotten cut from his team no obviously
not
in fact you know I think arguably if if
it was a white guys as a white woman so
if it was a if we keep the races the
same and it was a white guy
acting that way to career cream huntin
and he was treated the same way in
response I think probably there'd be
people taking cream hunts side saying
that he was he was he was in the right
they may even accuse the the the the
white guy of racism who knows what no
matter what anyone you know even if they
don't take cream on side I think they
were the response from everybody in that
situation would just be to yawn and say
who cares you know everyone would say
well these are just a bunch of drunk
people in a hallway at a hotel they got
into a scuffle whatever that's the
response everyone would have but not
with this There is obviously a double
standard here and it's a dump it's a
it's a double standard that I personally
am okay with I'm okay with the double
standard my problem is that feminists
and progressives should not be okay with
it they are ok with it but they
shouldn't because these are the people
who are always saying that there
shouldn't be a double standard when it
comes to men and women the standard
should be the same they should be
treated exactly the same that's what
feminists and progressives say yet when
it comes to situations like this they
all of a sudden abandon that position
and and that's the problem now before I
get into help into you know how
progressives should view cases like this
I'll just give you my take personally I
will say first of all it's very hard for
me to call the woman of victim in this
case I think that that's to say that she
was brutalized and she was a victim I
think is is absurd she chose to get into
a shouting match with this guy she
smacked him apparently in the in the
video she kept coming back to him she
could have just left but she didn't she
could have put the an end to the
confrontation at any time by just
leaving but she didn't probably because
she was drunk and so was he presumably
and so the situation just blew up from
there and she has some culpability in
that to say that she has no culpability
is to treat this grown adult woman like
a child
which she isn't
and that's from what I've seen the from
the responsive people watch this video
and they say all did that poor woman
that woman she's been victimized what do
you tell she she had a she played a role
in this and she also physically attacked
hunt so I think we need to we need to
stipulate that to begin with it's been
alleged by hunts friends that the woman
or one of the women hurled a racial slur
at him now I'm not sure if that's true
they also say that what started the
whole confrontation is that they were
partying with the girls in the room and
then they found out that the girls were
only 19 when they thought they were 21
and so they told the girls they had to
leave the women claim that the fight
started because hunt or one of the men
wanted to get intimate with the woman
and she refused so she was kicked out
and now who knows what really started it
I have no idea it's a he said she said
type of situation I think maybe we could
just like toss out the most extreme
accusations from either side and we
could say well maybe maybe that maybe
there was no racial slur and and they
weren't getting kicked out for refusing
to have sex with the men so let's just
put those to the side and were left with
a bunch of drunk idiots at 3 a.m. having
an argument that's basically what we're
left with now that said hunt himself
could have de-escalated the situation
but he didn't he could have walked away
but he didn't the kick at the end was
completely unnecessary
as I said agree just bad terrible just
retaliatory because he was angry that's
the only reason he did it
obviously it wasn't self-defense or
anything like that so he behaved very
wrongly
and apparently he also lied to his
employers about this situation so he
deserves to be fired just for that alone
and because I'm an old-fashioned kind of
guy and I admit that I'm old-fashioned I
do believe in chivalry and I believe
that women are the physically weaker
fairer sex and therefore we as men
should never use our strength against
them except in maybe some extreme cases
of self-defense
I which which this was not self-defense
at all he was not he was not fearing for
his life or his physical safety because
of this 19 year old drunk woman so I
ascribe to the maxim that a man should
never hit a woman
I do not ascribe to the maxim that all
women are helpless innocent flowers
I don't ascribe to that and I don't
think that a woman is automatically a
victim just because the man doesn't live
up to the chivalric standard I do expect
men to live up to that standard but not
all women are necessarily victims just
because men don't that's just my view
but what is the supposedly modern
enlightened feminist view well that view
is that men and women are equal and that
men should treat women exactly as they
would treat other men that's what we're
told all the time we're told that women
are not necessarily weaker than men and
they certainly shouldn't be treated as
if they're weaker that is the supposedly
modern feminist view when it comes to
the relationship between men and women
and if people are consistently applying
that view then they would look at
situations like this and they would say
well Kareem hunt is just treating that
girl exactly as he would treat any guy
if he got into a shoving match with a
guy and the guy smacked him in the face
he would react the same way presumably
probably worse I imagine that if it were
me and I got in twitch into a shouting
match with griemann and i smacked him in
the face
I would probably fare much worse than
the woman did so his crime isn't simply
that he attacked a woman it's that he
treated a woman almost like like he
would treat a guy he reacted to her
almost the same way that he would react
to any man that's his sin right
and if
the modern enlightened feminist person
is being consistent they would just
shrug their shoulders at this this the
same way they would if it was if it if
it was two men having ass altercation
again if the woman was a man of the same
physical stature nobody would care we
would all say well that's what happens
when you get into an altercation like
this with an NFL player that's what
happens you shouldn't do that but that
isn't what the modern enlightened
feminist says in this case all of a
sudden they rediscover chivalry and they
say that the worst thing in the world is
is that a man can do is hit a woman you
should never hit a woman they say the
problem is they make that statement and
they don't follow it through they don't
accept the full implications of that
statement like I said I have no problem
with the idea that a man should never
hit a woman as long as we allow for
certain qualifications so maybe I do
have a problem with that idea actually
legit to just say blanket statement a
man should never hit a woman is that's
obviously absurd there could be
legitimate cases of self-defense a man
has every right to assert himself
physically in an effort to defend
himself if he's actually being attacked
and really needs to defend himself but
aside from that yeah a man should not
hit a woman I believe in that maxim and
I believe in the truth that underlies
the maxim and that truth is this that
the sexes are not equal men and women
are different one is not inferior to the
other but they are different men are
stronger than women men are more
aggressive are more physical than women
the whole point of chivalry is to
recognize that fact and then to say to
men okay you have this strength you have
this aggression you have this
physicality more so than women do and so
you should use it in service to those
who are weaker to protect them not to
dominate them or intimidate them and and
that's why people don't like
chivalry these days because chivalry
begins with an acknowledgement of the
inequality of the sexes but progressives
won't acknowledge that they won't agree
with that yet they still say or they'll
still treat a man hitting a woman as
much much much worse than a man hitting
a man and again they can't claim that
well no just because this particular
woman with this happens to be smaller
and weaker than that particular man and
so that's why we're so upset about it no
that's not why they're upset because NFL
players get into fights with weaker men
all the time most men in in the world
are gonna be weaker than NFL players
these are some of the most you know
these gonna be some of the strongest and
biggest guys around so and you hear
about NFL players getting into fights at
bars and stuff like that all the time
and nobody cares nobody goes and looks
at the security footage and says wow
that that man seems a lot smaller and
then if I was you know NFL player and
and gets really upset about nobody cares
only if it's a woman do we care and that
doesn't make any sense if we're taking
the feminist view if we're gonna take
the feminist view and we're gonna take
it seriously then that reaction makes no
sense so what I would say to two
progressives and feminists is you've got
to decide like what's it gonna be are
men and women
unequal do we expect them to recognize
the inequality in each other and to and
to respond accordingly in other words
here's really the question that you have
to ask yourself when a man is
acting with a woman do you want him to
treat her like a woman to recognize the
differences to recognize that she's a
woman and treat her differently because
of it or do you want men to treat women
exactly as they would treat other men
you have to decide between those two you
can't have it both ways
you can't say well sometimes recognize
oh they're like a woman sometimes
pretend she's not a woman that doesn't
work that way it can't work that way
your message to men can that cannot be
your message I mean your message cannot
be something as arbitrary as that your
message to men is either forget about
the differences treat women like you
treat men or it's the treat a woman like
a woman what's it gonna be which is it
and then have the courage of your
convictions
stop being so cowardly have some courage
be consistent and if you're gonna say
well men should treat women like men
then you have to look at the cream hunt
situation watch the video and say no
okay I mean that's that's exactly what
he would have done to a man and if those
were a bunch of men going at it and
nobody would care that's what you have
to say only people like me only people
who are more conservative and
old-fashioned believe in chivalry we're
the only ones who really have any right
to be especially upset when a man hits a
woman because we do recognize the
differences and we do expect men to
treat women like women but if you don't
expect that you can't all of a sudden
change your tune
so just decide what's it gonna be and
and let me know what your answer is it
let everyone know what your answer is
and then we can proceed accordingly all
right something else in the news I
wanted to mention briefly president
Trump has thrown his support behind a
bipartisan measure called the first-step
Act and the idea what the first step act
is to reduce the federal prison
population and supposedly correct some
of the injustice is that the people in
that system have suffered so some of the
things that the bill will will will do
some of it seems pretty
I don't think anyone could have a
problem with it like for instance it
will end the practice of of shackling
pregnant women as they deliver their
babies
it also will make it easier to release
terminally ill and elderly prisoners so
they can live out the last few days or
months of their lives with their
families and it will it will try to
ensure that prisoners are placed within
driving distance of their families when
they're in prison so all of that is fine
I don't see why anyone would necessarily
oppose any of that the problem though is
that the bill intends to reduce the
federal prison population by a lot more
than just a small percentage of of
terminally ill and elderly prisoners it
wants to cut the population in half and
proponents of the bill say that it will
do this by providing a path for
nonviolent drug offenders and other
similar offenders who are not a danger
to their communities to be to be
released
well that sounds ok but let me read a
bit from a weekly standard piece which
enumerates the issues with this whole
approach it says but if the system is
too big the first step act might not be
the appropriate fix in its drive to act
Congress may pass a bill that would
unduly free numerous federal offenders
including many drug traffickers and some
four thousand prisoners whose early
release would come without regard to
their future dangerousness this is
because the federal system relative to
state and local incarceration is
comparably small just eight percent of
all prisoners in the u.s. are
incarcerated at the federal level about
180 thousand people total that number
has fallen year-over-year since 2012 of
those in the system today about 30
percent aren't carsick are serrated for
immigration offenses and are mostly
excluded from first step another 30
percent are in for drugs more than 97
percent of those are drug traffickers by
contrast there are only about 200
possession offenders in the federal
system the remaining 40 percent are
charged with a mix of fairly serious
crimes 12 percent for firearms offenses
12% for fraud and other white-collar
crimes about 3% for child pornography
offences and the remaining 10% or so for
a mix of mostly violent offenses so it
seems as though there just aren't enough
of the low-level drug offenders in the
federal system to make this work
these efforts should be concentrated on
the state level where most of the most
of the prisoners are in general and most
of the nonviolent prisoners are there so
I fully agree that we shouldn't really
be might be tossing drug addicts in
prison if somebody's only crime is
trying to buy heroin for themselves then
I think it's crazy to just toss those
people in prison especially when you
have so many violent people out there
who who I think are more deserving and
we should save the space for them but
that's not how you generally end up in
federal prison so when you hear about
this and people are talking about it
saying well it's bipartisan so it's
great first of all general rule you
should be especially suspicious of
bipartisan bills
it's the bite of the bipartisan ones are
the ones that you should be suspicious
about and in this case for good reason
because it's being sold it's just
they're targeting the federal prisoners
but the the types of prisoners that
they're supposedly looking to free and
let out and be merciful towards there
just aren't enough of those types in the
federal system to make for this to make
any sense whatsoever so like with with
most of the serious problems in society
if it's gonna be solved it has to be
solved on a more localized level and
that especially is the case here last
thing a radio station in Cleveland star
102 has banned the song baby it's cold
outside because the song allegedly
promotes date rape now this is an annual
tradition of course people getting upset
about this song because the song is
you've heard it obviously I assume the
song is sung by a man and a woman
and the woman spends the whole song
China can or the man spends all song
trying to convince the woman to spend
the night at his place well she keeps
saying that she's got to go and the
point that he keeps raising in the song
is that it's cold outside you know as as
the title suggests he also says that the
snow is up to your knees out there which
is kind of a legitimate concern to raise
I think he raises a few good points in
the song really he says that the snows
up to your knees
you can't drive the roads are
treacherous he says there are no cabs so
we have to assume that this woman is you
know a few miles probably from her house
the snows up to her knees the roads are
shut down you know what is she gonna do
walk through a blizzard so if you want
to be optimistic you would say that the
song is really the song is it's the song
isn't about sex at all the song is about
a man trying to save a woman's life by
stopping her from venturing out into a
blizzard in the middle of the night I
mean she could die he's trying to save
her life in the song now the more
cynical and perhaps correct
interpretation of the lyrics is that the
guy is just wants to be intimate with
the woman and so he's trying to convince
her to stay all right let's just say for
the sake of argument that that is really
what's going on in this song well I
would actually I would be fine with
people saying that the song is
inappropriate I would even be fine with
with radio stations deciding not to play
the song on their airwaves if they
applied that same standard and that same
criticism to 90% of the pop music and
the rap music out there because 90% of
it is all about men trying to have sex
with women and women trying to have sex
with men or some other combination of
sex is going on in these songs
that's what 90% of modern music is about
I mean 90% is a conservative estimate
probably maybe but might actually be
closer to like 100 percent and in most
cases
the point the sexual point is made in in
a way that is much cruder and and much
more vulgar so what's always interesting
about stuff like this is people hear
this baby it's cold outside and they say
oh you know that's really inappropriate
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
playing that song that's the kind of
thing that you would expect like you
would expect if someone is saying that
about a song like that you would expect
that person to have a huge problem with
almost all of the music on the radio not
just that one particular song and if
they do you know if you're someone who
you hate all this music and you don't
like that song because it's because it's
a hyper sexual in your mind then I say
fine
you know you're being consistent and and
I think maybe you're being a little
overly sensitive but that's that's fine
I totally respect that point of view but
to just single out that song while while
maintaining that all the rest of this
stuff is perfectly acceptable when it is
even more sexually charged it is even
more aggressive and as I said much
cruder and much more vulgar that just
doesn't make any sense
so yet again there is a an inconsistency
here I guess that's the theme today is
just people not consistently applying
whatever whatever standard they set they
set the standard and then they refuse to
consistently apply it and I think that's
I think that that's something we need to
you know look at and make an effort
whatever your principles are make an
effort to apply them consistently that's
the point all right hope you guys have a
blessed beginning of the Advent season
and I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed